[Music]
thank you
hi guys it's Quinn here if you enjoy my
videos consider hitting the like button
it's the only way the YouTube algorithm
really notices me
today we're going to talk about a
science fiction book that I bet most of
you have never heard of Rick reminders
low low is absolutely one of the best
graphic novels I've ever read and if
you've not read it I suggest you stop
this video and grab it because this is
absolutely worth your time money and
attention now if you don't care that
much about spoilers continue forth but
don't worry I won't be spoiling too much
of the story
in low almost all of the future humans
have migrated underwater and now all
live in Dome cities due to the fact that
the surface had become too hot for
normal human habitation this is because
this story is set billions of years in
our future and the sun has expanded to a
red giant the protagonists of our story
Stell Kane lives in the Dome City of
Salas with her husband and children
using robotic probes she desperately
searches for a new planet that can
support human life the Dome cities
themselves are crumbling the filtration
systems which keep them oxygenated are
becoming continuously less efficient the
citizens of all the known cities know
that they do not have long before none
of the Cities can support life
because of this Sallis and the other
Dome cities display many aspects of the
dying Society the governments are
corrupt people are addicted to drugs
that allow them to escape from reality
the populace has grown apathetic
depressed and careless Humanity had
nearly run out of Hope entirely and yet
one day a signal is received and a
planet has been found but still will
have to journey to a world now unknown
to humankind to collect these
coordinates and I'll just let you know
right now that this journey is not easy
Rick reminder pushes these characters to
their breaking point and really test who
they are and really test how long they
can actually cling to the hope of a
better future I think one of the biggest
themes of This Book Is that hope is all
that matters how do we hold on to hope
when all seems lost well if you've given
up on Hope then All Is Lost anyway so
the only reasonable option is to keep
fighting to as they say rage against the
dying of the light the character
stellkane is essentially the embodiment
of this concept relentlessly hopeful in
the face of devastating odds
I remember when I was your age finding
out that our world would one day be
consumed by the Sun
what a waste of time all this is it
seemed to me no matter what we build no
matter what we do no matter what the sun
will expand and eventually consume it
all
I felt like a powerless Observer of the
end of my species it wasn't until I met
your mother that I could see any reason
to try that we can find strength in the
unity of family
strength enough to find a better
tomorrow
in this book really centers the Kane
family and their Misadventures they are
put through a lot and the relationships
with one another are so complex and
realistic there's something about the
way a remitter writes these characters
that makes them come alive you really
feel like you know them you really root
for them and this of course makes the
book really hard to read sometimes
because you really don't want anything
bad to happen to these characters
But ultimately as I said this book is
about hope so there is a light at the
end of the tunnel
the World building is another giant
highlight of this graphic novel The Dome
cities are distinct from each other they
feel ancient and they each have their
own distinct history and culture one
thing I find particularly interesting is
the concept of the Helmsman apparently
in the early days of the Dome City there
had been several Helmsman suits each
capable of immense destruction as the
eons passed most of those suits were
lost to time or destroyed the last suit
in salus belongs to the family of Joel
Kane the husband of stelkane having been
passed down throughout the generations
the suits only responded to specific DNA
which is why it was important that they
be passed down through the family line
Humanity has also begun to evolve and
diverge into different groups there are
many species of humanoid aquatic
creatures like the vampiric mermaids who
dwell in the deep dark places of the
ocean
the world above has also continued to
develop separately from the world below
the humans which had been left behind
had adapted to the new sun and continued
their own Society on the surface
creating essentially what was a Utopia
however much of their culture is based
around hatred for those below they were
embittered because their own ancestors
had been left to die on the surface eons
ago when the ones in their Dome cities
refused to rescue them because of this
the surface dwellers who call themselves
The Burnt have no intention of allowing
the Dome citizens to escape the Earth as
their ancestors had been left to die
they would allow those below to perish
though we neosapiens are descended from
Homo sapiens we are burnt by the surface
we adapted to the good Sun instead of
hiding from it a sun that is slowly
expanding still becoming a red giant
star that will one day engulf the Earth
our small-minded ancestors saw this as
their Doom fearful and superstitious
monkeys have always misunderstood the
sun we however know it is part of the
natural and cosmically intended
evolution of our species
neanderthals and Crow magnets both came
from the same common ancestor but the
superior Cro-Magnon survived while their
inferior cousins were destroyed
similarly we burnt our Superior to Homo
sapiens having faced our Natural
Evolution while our ancestors fled to
the depths of the sea we have adapted
and flourished put an end to all war
famine and disease created the first to
post-scarcity society I found this
particular part of the story where we
encountered the burnt to be so
interesting evolution is powerful
throughout the eons of the existence of
life on Earth any species that has
failed to adapt to changes in
environment has gone extinct but
curiously often rapid changes facilitate
rapid adaptation this in addition to the
radiation of the sun which caused
mutations occur is what allowed the
humans in this series on the surface to
evolve they became the neo-sapiens the
next stage in human evolution the story
of life on the surface of Earth didn't
just end when most humans went
underwater it didn't just end when we
left once they were gone a new Society
took their place perhaps a better
Society than the one which existed
before when it comes to Earth there are
life forms which fill every possible
Niche they exist and thrive in places
that would be instantly deadly to most
life to quote one of my favorite
childhood movies Jurassic Park life
finds a way this concept of course has
been explored in many science fiction
series and I really enjoy how remainder
uses it here
now if you've never read any of Rick
remender's work you are missing out
because he is an absolute Master at what
he does and when we combine recommenders
incredible story his Rich complex and
deeply emotionally compelling characters
with the beautiful artwork of Greg
tuccini then we get what I personally
believe to be a masterpiece and I'm not
exaggerating so if you're into great
world building great characters and
great story lines that keep you on your
toes this is the book for you absolutely
100 get low and I'll definitely be
covering some more of the lore in future
videos thanks guys
just a heads up for those of you that
may be interested my next graphic novel
the LIE behind the star is launching
February 2023 you can sign up now to get
on the email mailing list to get
notified as soon as it launches more
information on my website link in the
description thank you guys so much
[Music]